[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts do
you have any favorite memories or funny
stories from your time working that
stage wow well let's see a member of New
Year's Eve one night it was me Dan Soder
Michelle wolf Gary veter Sam Morrell
Joel it was like a great group and
Michelle wolf got so drunk she blacked
out and I think fell asleep in the Green
Room that was fun uh I remember watching
uh I saw Bill Burr there and he did that
special I can't remember what the name
of it maybe Let It Go but it was sold
out it was before he was huge and he
sold it out and me and Nate bargatzi
want to watch and it was Unreal he did
the whole bit about uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger he's like this guy's been
killing he married to Kennedy he was Mr
Universe then he became the governor of
a state he can't even pronounce
I can't remember the special that was
yeah but I got to see it I got to see
his Rise
um I saw Paul Mooney there I saw Doug
Stanhope there and he said David tell in
the back and he goes Dave what are you
doing here and David tell goes well I
heard a white voice coming out of
Caroline so I had to see who it was they
were they were booking a lot of black
accents yeah so uh you know Dave's the
funniest guy on the planet so yeah so
many great memories I hooked up with a
waitress there years ago uh good times
good times do you remember any um any
specific like times where someone really
got you good with a chirp I mean I
remember when an entire uh crowd got me
good with a chirp so I played junior
college basketball with which you know
can either be high level or really low
level it kind of depends where you play
we ended up being a pretty serious team
that played against division one you
know guys that couldn't they had like
you know 40s on their SATs yeah so they
couldn't go play anywhere but they were
like athletic freaks and we played
Sullivan County Community College in
Upstate New York it's like an hour and a
half outside of the city and the the uh
the entire room I was like one of two
white people in the entire 500 plus you
know sat with for whatever reason yeah
community college games were the [ __ ]
we've never got crowds like that at our
home gym but for whatever reason this
was like the social event of the evening
their entire campus packed into this gym
and again I'm used to this I played
Hoops my entire life so that never
bothered me before at all but this
entire crowd as if they got together
beforehand uh every time I touched the
ball chanted cracker so literally 500
strong every time I touch the ball we're
just like crap
cracker and this is like [ __ ] this is
not even the end dude so this is like
this is back when I had you know a ton
of self-confidence before life has truly
kicked me in the teeth you know and I
thought anything could go wrong you're
still balling yeah yeah exactly I had
that mentality so my first shot I put up
no problem I put up my first shot
probably two or three minutes into the
game seven several cracker chance later
and I just drill a perfect swing pass
from the top of the key three and I look
into the crowd because they're only sat
on one side and it's just 500 wall of
people and I look and I kind of side
like side yeah yeah
and I grab my nuts like a slight kind of
grab of my nuts Baker Mayfield yeah and
they're just like silent and then after
I mean you know it probably was like two
beats three beats but it felt like a
minute
totally silent some guy goes probably
the first shot you ever hit [ __ ]
entire place
erupted in cheers and I was just like my
soul like Shang sung from Mortal Kombat
touchdown and put his hand on my
shoulder there's no coming back from
that nothing
you gotta check out you gotta ask for a
sub that's that's hilarious dude when
they that's so funny when there's a
silence and you can have a whole captive
audience like in public like that and
even with doing like really edgy like I
don't like to be filtered I like to make
[ __ ] up jokes I like to make political
jokes
um I have a podcast called Pier 69 we
you know we push it sometimes
um and I think people get it but you
even have to be careful sometimes you
make a joke and you're like oh that's
edgy and then people were like yeah I
love that and you're like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I was kidding and I feel like
you like it too much and it's weird
that's funny that's like that's like a
big J uh oakerson joke he had a joke
where he's like it would be weird for me
if I was saying like racist jokes and
everyone in the crowd wasn't laughing if
they were just like yachting their head
like yep I'd be like I'd be like what
this is not a political rally we're just
like yeah you're pushing on the edge
it's funny to say the wrong thing even
when you know it's wrong how did the
kissing thing start
um well they realized that I'll just
tell them anything they want to hear and
then they start asking me about my love
life and then I was like well you know
like I'm trying to you know
[ __ ] comedians
like because that's who I'm around all
the time and then they're like let's
bring one out and then they were like is
she here and then they're like yeah
she's here and then like she was sort of
like
oh gross he's he's where the worst I
hate him and then they're like does
anyone want to kiss him to like kind of
balance out yeah
the fact that she was clearly not
attracted to me
and then uh that girl kissed me and then
like every week tubby was like is it
okay if I do that every week uh some
people are weird about their moms
watching or whatever and I was like yeah
I mean
I uh don't live my life in a way that my
mom like she's not like the uh one
person that I'm trying to impress you
know I kind of need to live my life so
uh but yeah I mean he started doing it
every week and uh it was fun and then
people stopped wanting to kiss me for
whatever reason because they saw the 30
other ones beforehand yeah I always
wondered as a Bills fan if it's a touchy
subject no no I love OJ you know I say
you know it's a shame what happened to
Nicole and Ron but I mean the man ran 2
000 yards
yeah the Heisman you know he's still up
on our wall of fame
yeah he's also still he sells the bust
up in um
in the Pro Football Hall of Fame but I
didn't know he was still in the stadium
that's yeah yeah I'm sure what I mean
we're supposed to get a new one in uh
2026 here coming up so yeah I'm sure his
name will like be forgotten in the move
right now just lost lost people love OJ
but if you go to the bill Stadium you'll
see tuna OJ jerseys that's crazy because
if you think about that compared to like
how how they did Joe paw when all that
went down taking down the stats just
erasing him from history basically and
that was more the institution than it
what like think about what happened when
they did do that when they fired them
there was like riots as if George Floyd
was murdered you know what I mean so it
was like bananas that's kind of how
Bill's fans are we're like
you know it's a shame he murdered those
people but you know he's still yeah of
all time that's true that's the white
person's George Floyd is
Statue being removed they're not missing
too much but there's not over much yeah
yeah and Cleveland did hilarities a few
times and then great Club yeah really
good club I performed there in 2016 I
did a weekend and
um I was staying at the hotel right
across the way downtown and on Sunday
there was a note slipped under my door
that says the RNC starts tomorrow all
hotels are sold out in the whole region
for the week and you cannot extend your
stay you must yeah you must be out of
your room I was like that is the most
Republican thing you could have done I
also learned this about uh that week
when the RNC comes to town all of the
bars get to extend their closing hour to
four because there's so much partying
and Coke and drinking wow and apparently
it is busy season in for male
prostitutes I mean female prostitutes
too but there's a lot of like you know
Lindsey Graham types so they're like I'm
gonna have me a little a little feast
tonight wow I never would have thought
that I would have thought these were
some old dudes that were boring as [ __ ]
and then they'd love you to think yeah
yeah they're doing a great job listen
I'm sure Democrats party real hard too
but we're just not as fun as Republicans
the only thing I remember from being
there during that time was that was the
year that the Cavs won the the NBA
finals and I was at the watch party in
game seven when they came back from that
one three lead one of the greatest
Knights of my life and greatest
accomplishments that I've ever had was
watching my team
win that Championship but I was yeah I
was in the everyone gets hand jobs
tonight everyone gets hand jobs that was
the second busiest time for male
processes
dude there was a um just recently there
was some kid at a carnival that was like
over the weight limit yeah that was in
Orlando oh really yeah he died wow yeah
yeah yeah yeah no like they didn't put
his harness on correctly or it just I
don't know exactly what happened but I
saw the video of it which is horrible
don't watch the video of it it's all
right we're putting the video in right
now and we're gonna take a quick break
to watch the video link in the
description
if you want to see the Fun Spot death
yeah that's your new compilation series
on joke world yes
like is people dying
dude [ __ ] [ __ ] all this like stand-up
comment yeah let's talk about it go in a
New Direction it gives you [ __ ] yeah
what we're doing now is compilations now
that I have this audience hostage
yeah you've garnered enough subscribers
you can show them the content that you
want out yeah
hey welcome yeah welcome to the live
League podcast it's literally half of
what your mom's house
that's true that is literally your mom's
house
yeah it's just a girl giggling at Isis
beheading yes yeah
is this funny yes did you like this yeah
this is what I laugh at it's it's it's
bad Neil Brennan's like throwing up he's
like yeah yeah like this is good stuff
Danny Brown is cackling at uh some kid
falling off of [ __ ] oh that's a zip
line or whatever the hell having some
perspective on it it was pretty nuts
just any night of the week it'll be like
Burr Sebastian Segura Rogan and then and
then me so what's interesting is like
I'm on those lineups just like nobody
it's bizarre because you may be a good
comedian
but when nobody knows who you are
um it's
it's a different thing like then you
have Joey Diaz as well because these
guys are like great Comedians and people
know who they are so then it was fun and
I enjoy those times and everything but I
have noticed a little difference where
now I feel like because it is not so
star heavy like there still are but it's
not the [ __ ] Insanity that it was
right
I feel like um
like me and some other comedians are
able to kind of our signal is able to
reach audiences a little more that makes
sense because it because the
gravitational pull of Rogan is like so
big or like or like Burr or people who
are so when it was that stacked even if
you're a funny comedian if you're
unknown it's hard to cut through that
noise yeah and I found like in this new
era it's been a little easier for me to
cut through the noise yeah and it's not
even like like we're saying like known
but people like Bill Burr and Joe and
Theo and Joey Diaz these are people that
like fans know but there's people that
are obsessed with them like not even
like just regular fans they have like
super super like crazy fans that almost
like they could go to the store see
those guys and then still be you know in
awe that they just saw Joey Diaz while
you're on stage all they're thinking
about is I can't remember when JoJo said
that exactly so it's like and we're like
two different frequencies like I love
Joey but like we're we're like different
if you're in it's like Metallica's a
great band and then so is Michael
Jackson yeah there's not a ton of
crossover yeah and sometimes that
happens with comedy where if you have an
act that is a certain type of frequency
that 80 of the crowd is there for
even though you have your own thing and
Merit it's going to be hard to kind of
like get into the hearts of yeah that
other 80 I'd say Joey Diaz does not have
a lot of frequency similarities with
anyone
like that I think it cuts through a lot
of frequencies though no matter who you
are it's just like a whirlwind yeah
enjoy it we don't have to talk about the
Columbia thing but when you went on Joe
Rogan which is a podcast obviously I
just said Joe Rogan that's obviously
that's a podcast that's very big and was
there any nerves I mean you're a little
less established than you are now just
because that's how years work and time
like was it like nervous going in there
like how did the only thing I was
nervous about was uh smoking his weed
well I'm glad he didn't offer because I
definitely would have said yes and then
that [ __ ] would have gone off the rails
because uh I got a fairly light
tolerance when it comes to
like famous people weed but you gotta
say yes yes
so I didn't have to I didn't have to
indulge was he smoking I don't I don't
think so I don't think he was no he
wasn't that'd be kind of weird I guess
if he was yeah what do you get excited
for nowadays doing it 15 years is every
time you go on stage still the same pop
internally or like what do you what do
you seek out now I get to do college
shows those are fun for me because I
like I mean they pay you a lot of money
and you get to travel somewhere and just
do like one show so that's nice I like
yeah I like those because those are easy
underneath local local [ __ ] of course
nice but um I got excited for uh doing
shows with like big names who I'm a fan
of yeah like you saw me at Big J yeah
yeah I was just about to say that yeah
he saw me open for Big J that was my
fourth weekend with big J and uh yeah I
get excited working with people I'm fans
of I mean I've gotten work with a lot of
my heroes over the years like Anthony
Jeselnik Doug Stanhope Nick Swardson
Kevin Nealon recently but yeah just a
list of Pablo Francisco was like the
first person I ever got to open up for
and I was such a huge fan of his but
yeah like I've gotten to work with most
of my heroes and it's been pretty cool
has there ever been a time where it's
like don't meet your Heroes they really
oh yeah and I can't talk about it but
there was a hero who took me on the road
with him and he just was a complete
psychopath really just a wild drunk and
just abusive
to me verbally in general just really
mean and it broke my heart because I was
a huge fan yeah and I grew up watching
him on TV loving him and then to have
him just like
just be mean to me for no reason too it
was all his own like drunken delusion so
that was a shame and you know and I've
tried to mend it with him and there's
been opportunities but he just seems to
refuse to want to have any holy [ __ ]
with me it was Bert Kreischer no were
you there around the time that the Dave
Chappelle thing happened I was there
after I wasn't there at the same time
but I the security really got heightened
after that in fact even I had my own
personal security guard Netflix had for
me so wow at all my shows they came to
my show they stayed until I left that's
pretty cool that's a good response yeah
when I left the venue they left but they
stayed uh even I did a show on Friday
and then I got asked to do a second show
and the the security guard stayed wow so
I felt like it was really unnecessary I
feel like I could use an attack on stage
use the Press yeah that would be fine
for me
um that sucks
sales went up really big when he got
slapped I mean I I would take a slap for
for uh up in the ticket sales you know
you heard it here first I've been
slapped for no money before that's a
good way to think about it if anyone out
there is at Dusty's next few shows and
is feeling bold
he welcomes a slap yeah in fact I've
never got paid for getting punched you
know I've been punched many times and
it's always for free there's so it goes
on and on um Let me give the proper
credit here upload it to YouTube at joke
world that's who did it
um and the world is wrld
I cut this for over like four minutes I
love it and he really overlapped your
reactions to like yeah yeah it's so good
yeah it always amazes me because the
amount of time it must take to do this
thank you to all the comedians who are
guest on the joke World podcast this
past year and also thank you to all the
viewers and subscribers who made the
show possible please let me know in the
comments you'd like us to interview
going into 2023 goodbye God love you
you're a mention if I was gay I'd blow
you same here
thank you
foreign
[Music]